first it was defunding the police now
liberals have a new way to make it
harder for cops to do their jobs
new york city becoming the first in the
country to end
qualified immunity for police officers
which makes it easier to sue cops
over claims of misconduct jesse is this
the end of police
in new york city and surely other
liberal cities will follow suit
even if it's a failure well it's going
that way you combine this with defund
the police
bail reform and then yanking this
qualified immunity away it's going to
kill proactive policing they're just
going to stay in their cars they're not
going to
community police are not going to walk
the beat they'll just stay back and take
less risks
it's going to increase it's going to
decrease
foot pursuits and vehicle pursuits so
why would you chase a suspect all around
if you know there's going to be an
altercation
or you could possibly lose your
livelihood people are going to resist
arrest more because
felons know you get a hot shot lawyer
they take a chance
something happens you get it on tape and
then they'll file the lawsuit
and it's going to create an industry of
frivolous lawsuits
firms set up just to slap multiple
police officers
with ridiculous charges anytime anybody
gets arrested
and it's basically going to incapitate
incapacitate entire police departments
so they're so frozen they can't do
anything and ultimately
it's going to hurt communities of color
more because they're the ones that need
strong police presence because without
it gangs are going to run wild
traffickers are going to have their say
and it's going to hurt people one just
this year in new york year to date
murders are up 12 percent shootings are
up 40 percent
how is this going to bring crime down
well what we have here is a need for
balance dagan i think you need to
really root out bad cops people who are
hurting people abusing people
people who are involved with graf
corruption
and you also need to protect good cops
and what we have in america is a
situation where too many communities
because of the power of the police
unions much as we talk about the power
of teachers union protecting bad
teachers
you have powerful police unions that
protect
and hide abuse by police in this country
and so what you're seeing now is an
effort to say well you're going to have
to be held accountable in some
way it's hard to get around the police
union so maybe the civil courts
are the way to do it i mean you know if
there's no accountability
it's harder to say you know what the
cops are on the right side and i stand
with the police
but qualified immunity is not a free
pass brian to begin with
it is and i over prepare for this
segment i only have 30 seconds but real
quick
i talked to a lawyer i talked to a
police consumer today you basically want
these people
the the police to raise your kids uh
they're on the street they're they're
actually trying to give people
directions as well as uh
save people from being victims of crimes
and now what you're saying is
we're gonna haul them into court yes
it's true they'll be defended by
the police force right by the state but
if you get called into court because
you're a good cop and three criminals
all you into court you're gonna get
fired
and after you get fired you lost a good
cops you know what they're gonna say
either i'm not doing it you're not gonna
get quality people becoming cops
conscientious people or number two is
i'm not going to be aggressive i'm not
going to put my family in jeopardy in my
career my pension
i'm going to sit back here and unless
crime comes to me i'm not coming to it
and when people come back to work
come back to the city when this pandemic
is fully over they're going to realize
it's the wild west in urban america
yeah but you can't have a gun so you
can't defend yourself if you're just a
law-abiding citizen
not in this city you can't dana well i i
should yield my time to brian because he
actually talked to somebody but i do
think in terms of recruitment
you will see a just a drastic drop in
people who
want to become police officers and that
is a real calling
people want to help protect their
communities i have a feeling
dagon this this will end badly and it
didn't have to be this way there were
many people
especially in the union police union
that were willing to
let's talk about it let's look at some
of these reviews let's figure this out
without having to take such a drastic
step
well said i